participer à une campagne présidentielle
et tenter de remporter une élection
c'est le but du nouveau jeu de société
la course à la présidence créé par un
habitant de guyancourt l'idée lui est
venue liens non je pense que le premier
confinement la crise vécue différemment
nous on a fait pas mal de jeux de
société mon acte pour mieux avec les
jeux qu'on avait et au bout d'un moment
je me suis dit pourquoi pas essayer de
créer un jeu moi même donc donc je les
fais je me suis lancée on a fait
quelques parties on a bien aimé
et voilà comment c'est venu à partir de
12 ans entre deux et six personnes
peuvent jouer le but
incarnez un candidat et réussir par tous
les moyens à remporter des électeurs au
fur et à mesure des tours on va devoir
prendre la décision à chaque à chaque
moment de notre campagne finalement de
prendre tel ou tel investissement pour
développer sa stratégie de campagne
donc ça va être soit via des promesses
politiques soit via des actions ou des
des cartes coups bas pour aller attaquer
les adversaires
le but n'est pas d'éduquer à la
politique mais simplement de jouer et
avec beaucoup de second degré le jeu est
disponible en précommande sur un site de
financement participatif en attendant sa
sortie en magasin
si tout va bien dès que je vais les
recevoir à partir de septembre si si si
les délais sont respectés
je pourrais d'être directement en
envoyer dans certaines boutiques
partenaires qui accepteront de les
vendre donc déjà dans les boutiques aux
alentours et après au fur et à mesure
toutes les boutiques qui seront
intéressés en france
la cagnotte en ligne lancé il y a deux
semaines a déjà atteint 80 % de son
objectif